foreign
is on the line in Philadelphia Tyrell
how can we help
hey guys I hope all is well it is
working out thank you I'm reaching out
because I work as a property manager and
I have a few uh side hustles that I do
as well I have a vehicle that I
purchased and it's probably a stupid
purchase but basically I owe 39 000 on
this on this Jeep because it's a nice
cheap and it's worth about 29 000 so I'm
upside down about ten thousand dollars
okay my uncle booties
sorry
no go ahead you're great I'm sorry Tyra
go ahead okay no worries my uncle
believes that I should uh I also have
some money coming in I'll work as a
broker and I have some bills that I'm
closing and I have about say about 15
000 permanent soon
and he believes that I should just pay
off my lower debts refinance the vehicle
to get a lower note
instead of
um paying the Delta and getting the jeep
completely off of my credit
okay so what other debt do you have
um so I'm in I'm in the hole about 79
000 total okay and that's um I have I
have four cars total three of woods I
went out on Toro so they actually make
some money I have about another
um everything else is pretty much credit
card and Home Improvement okay can we
walk through this really quick because I
think this this will help us of the
three of the three other cars that you
rent out on Touro I'm assuming you owe
money on all three is that right
yeah can you walk us through that uh
let's just say car number one you choose
what that is how much do you owe on that
and what is it worth
okay car number one on Toro there's I
have a Chevy Malibu right uh I owe 13
000 on that it's worth about eight
thousand
and then I have two Nissan versas
they're both about nine thousand and
they're worth a little bit more than
that actually
and last but not least is my personal
vehicle my daily driver which is my Jeep
I owe 39 000 on that which is you know
only worth about 20. how much do you
make Tyrell a year
uh it it varies but last year I made a
hundred thousand a hundred thousand okay
does that include the turo side income
yes
how much are you making a month on all
three of those cars together round
numbers on the turo cars
uh monthly on the Toro cars I'm making
roughly about 2500.
what are your car payments on the three
combined
about six hundred dollars combined
okay all right I wanted to gather that
information Rachel what are you thinking
okay so Tyrell here's the deal we we
said this in another segment and it's
just the truth what we have found over
three decades of doing this to create
wealth lasting wealth the right way from
point A to point B one of the biggest
things you can do is eliminate debt
and not have any payments and so when
I'm looking at the turo stuff and you're
like yeah I took out loans to get these
cars because it's kind of a business
thing it's a side hustle so like I know
you have the motivation and the
wherewithal to make money you're like I
wanna I wanna be doing some stuff but
with all of this debt flying around it
it is sucking not only your energy but
also your income and what you're doing
so if I were you if I woke up in your
shoes today
well well before I do the whole plan you
had a you said you had a home
improvement loan what was that for how
much it was done when we bought our
house a few years ago the HVAC blue and
they put it on what looked like a credit
card it was frankly bank but uh all
about uh 4 000 on that right now 4 000
on that okay
honestly Tyrell I would sell the two
nine thousand you said you can make some
money off that maybe you make you know I
don't know three four what do you think
what do you think those are worth the
two nine thousand dollar versus what are
they worth
they're worth right around uh ten
thousand maybe eleven right so you may
walk away from two groups but you just
knocked out eighteen thousand dollars in
debt yeah do you have any savings
uh I have about five grand savings five
Grand Savings okay so I would have a
401k okay so I would pause 401K
investing do not worry about investing
right now uh once you sell the two cars
you're gonna be able to knock out the
four thousand dollars with your four
thousand dollars in savings you're gonna
have two thousand dollars left from the
two cars that you sold and then I would
start working to pay off or to sell the
uh the first car that you're not your
primary car but the term the Malibu for
thirteen thousand
um you're that's what you you owe
thirteen thousand you're only gonna get
you know eight thousand for it but yeah
are you saying we take the 4K out of
savings leaving him with a thousand
that's his emergency fund baby step one
yes and with the Thousand you're gonna
make on the two verses I wanna make sure
you heard what she said we're knocking
out the debt on all three of those turo
cars that and the HVAC the four thousand
dollars okay that's what I was wanting
to do the HVAC first I would do the HVAC
first because it's four thousand well
then you got that so then you got to
work on the the Malibu not that out yep
and then you're gonna work on that card
next and then honestly uh
you know we always say don't have 50 of
your income tied up in vehicles and if
you can't pay off your primary car in 18
months yeah you may look at selling it
and having to take out a hit of ten
thousand dollars of a small loan but if
you think you can pay it off in 18
months Tyrell you can keep your primary
car and that'll be the last thing that
you pay off yeah but I would get rid of
all this you just have stuff floating
around and honestly the the clarity that
comes when you don't have all of this
stuff that you're you're trying to
manage and all of it and you focus on
your real estate what you're doing and
then even get a side gig that you're not
having to go into debt for you can
always do that and actually I would
encourage you to do that as you're
paying off this debt
um but I would I would realign your
energy and where you're looking to make
money off of debt and look to rewire
that to a place that actually is just
bringing you in income and not paying
payments does that make sense
yeah that makes a lot of sense I really
appreciate that yeah I know there was a
lot there sorry I hope I hope I I angled
that correctly for you and
it is clear yeah but there the the big
thing here is I think you're a really
hard worker I think you're motivated to
make money and I think that if you just
Channel all of that the right way versus
using the bank's money by taking out all
these like small loans and trying to do
this churro thing and you focus all of
your energy on actually a side hustle
that you're killing it and you take this
15 grand and you throw it more at your
debt that's coming in um that 15 grand
that you're going to have for your
commission all of that all of this is
going to be bubbling up Tyrell and I
think this time next year you could be
completely debt free without question
and working your way towards an
emergency fund having some liquid cash
again and then going back to retirement
investing and all of it yeah and Terrell
our gift to you to get you started we're
going to get you in FPU I want you to
take it on us because you need to see
that debt snowball working for other
people at the same time that you're
doing it and then my final encouragement
so hang on the line where to get you an
fbu but I also want to tell you this if
I was in your shoes I would absolutely
get rid of the distraction
and I would put my efforts into real
estate because the upside there is so
much greater and you're entrepreneurial
man I mean you you've got the drive I
think this is a focus issue and I think
it's a discipline issue and I think
you've learned the hard lesson it's not
worth buying a brand new car I don't
care how cool the Jeep commercial is
during the Super Bowl and believe me it
made me think about it it got me all
patriotic and I want a Jeep you know but
here's the deal like it doesn't pay off
because now you're looking at getting
out of that deal so you know I think
you've learned the lessons young man I
think your future is really bright let's
get you an FPU let's give you the clear
path and some accountability and some
community that you'll get and I think
Rachel's right we're gonna look back my
friend and you're going to be a baby
steps millionaire because you got the
hustle that's right that's a great point
about the side hustle yes if you're
already in something like a real acryl
estate that you just make some Great
Commission and you put more time into
that you could kill it yeah man I love
we've got we had some calls uh when was
it the last like I guess Wednesday when
I was on with Dave two different times
we were doing the millionaire theme our
real estate agents no college degree
yeah
everyday Millionaires and they're making
300 a year selling real estate I'm like
man what a what a what a world we live
in those are my people I know no degree
required baby I don't need to degree to
be successful I don't need a degree to
make six figures